les aficionados de la mode attend dès
cette date avec impatience les soldes
d'hiver ont débuté ce mercredi au
janvier en france dans ce centre
commercial outlet implanté aux
clayes-sous-bois les portes se sont
ouvertes à 8 heures deux heures plus tôt
que d'habitude
pour répondre à cette attente bah je
viens faire les soldes en faites pas
pour profiter des bonnes affaires
surtout donc j'espère faire de bonnes
trouvailles aujourd'hui et puis à faut
venir tout d'elle dès l'ouverture comme
ça on est sûr de pas être déçu et
trouver des taillas qu'il nous faut
franchement nous ne sommes pas des
grands spécialistes du shopping et c'est
l'opportunité qui fera nos achats budget
une sans limite quoi ses coups de coeur
en général je viens le premier jour des
soldes pour trouver l'article qui aurait
peut-être disparu les jours suivants
donc en général j'ai le premier jour et
puis je reviens quelques jours après au
total le centre commercial a enregistré
plus de dix mille visiteurs sur ce
premier jour des soldes
le week-end s'annonce lui prolifique
pour la structure avec plus de cinquante
mille clients attendus la première
semaine représente la première semaine
en chiffre d'affaires de l'année donc
elle est très importante en premier
c'est effectivement le prêt-à-porter et
les souliers et dans un second temps
c'est tout le linge de maison les les
valises marche aussi très très bien dès
le premier jour pendant ces six semaines
la structure va engranger près de 20% de
son chiffre d'affaires les soldes
d'hiver se termineront le 21 février
prochain
[Musique]